apropos novel therapy. So I'll talk about an agent we all know very well and are very familiar with
and its role in PTCL. So good morning, everybody. Glad to ring in the last day. Glad to be here.
It's been a fantastic meeting and thanks for coming this morning. These are my disclosures.
So for everybody who is not as awake as I am this morning, just the mechanism of action of
brantoxamab, you probably are all very familiar with. It's an antibody drug conjugate that targets
CD30. The CD30 portion is coupled to a tubulin or spindle toxin. MMAE gets internalized in the
lysosome degraded. The MMAE will interfere with spindle formation or tubulin formation
and apoptosis occurs. So initially, in the first one clinical trial of brantoxamab and CD30,
positive lymphoma.
Thus, the majority of the patients had Hodgkin lymphoma. However, there were two patients as well
with anaplastic large cell lymphoma, which uniformly and strongly expresses CD30. So a
very good target for brantoxamab with dodenon. These two patients achieved a complete response.
A couple of years later, we had a dedicated study just to anaplastic large cell lymphoma
out positive or negative in the relapse setting with single agent brantoxamab that was published by
Barbara Pro and colleagues in the JCO in 2012. And there you saw an overall response rate of 86%
and a CR rate of 57%, which was really fantastic with a median progression-free survival of over
one year. And there even are some people out in the tail who stopped brantoxamab after a year
and about 10% or so, 10 to 20% of those who achieved the CR needing no further therapy.
Most patients experience at least reduction in their size of the lesions.
Now, how about brantoxamab in non-ALCL? So a couple of years later, led by Steve Horvitz and
colleagues, we saw a phase two multicenter trial. And there the responses are, as expected, lower
with an overall response rate of 41%. And they broke it down by AITL and PT-CLNOS, which were the
first, which made up actually only two subgroups of patients. And the response rate was numerically
higher in the AITL group at 54% compared to PT-CLNOS, 33%, and a corresponding CR rate of 38%
versus 14%. Just want to not make too many assumptions based on these small subgroups,
because later in the ECHELON2 trial, for example, we see that AITL in the subgroup of analysis did
worse. So I'm not sure we can put too much stock in
saying that there is a differential response. However, the medium progression for survival was
significantly longer for AITL with 6.7 months, and the duration of response was shorter in PT-CL.
I think what's most interesting, though, what we saw in this study is when they performed the
central CD30 review with central staining, they saw that many of the responses occurred at less
than 10%. And even some patients who had, I don't know, more than 50% or less than 50% or less than
50%, they said no, as was pointed out yesterday, visible CD30 staining on IHC. So CD30 by itself
doesn't seem to be a very good biomarker for response in T-cell lymphoma. We all are very
familiar with the ECHELON2 trial, where patients with peripheral T-cell lymphoma that had at least
10% CD30 expression were randomized to receive either BV plus CHIP, so brentuximab, replacing the
vincristin or oncovin in CHOP compared to CHOP chemotherapy. And due to regulatory
requirements in the European Union, the majority of the patients, so about 70 plus percent had
anaplastic large cell lymphoma, so 316 compared to about 120 patients with other subtypes.
But clearly, brentuximab plus CHIP came out as the winner with a significant reduction in progression-free
survival and even overall survival for the entire group. When you look at the subgroup analysis,
as I had alluded to, it seems to benefit the most patients with anaplastic large cell lymphoma
and for AITL and PTCL. With very small numbers, it's not as clear. And here you look at the
progression-free and overall survival for ECHELON2 at the five-year follow-up for PTCL, NOS, and AITL.
So PFS is at the top, overall survival at the bottom,
the curves are about similar. And as I had mentioned, if you put too much,
a lot of stock in the subgroup analysis, it looked actually for AITL that CHOP did better,
but which, again, I don't think we can put too much faith in that subgroup analysis, other than
it's certainly not worse than CHOP. One subtype I wanted to draw attention to is enteropathy-associated
T cell lymphoma, so an intestinal lymphoma that's in a significant proportion also expresses CD30.
And we have traditionally poor outcomes. In the bottom right, you see that with CHOP or CHOAB or
more intense chemotherapy in consolidation with an auto transplant, you get about a two-year overall
survival of just under two years. Here, investigators had an induction cycle of four cycles of BV-chipped
and intensification with etoposide and high-dose methotrexate followed by a stem cell transplant.
After four cycles of BV-chipped, the overall response rate was 79% and the CR at 64% increased
to 71%. And in the end, with the whole package, the investigators saw a progression-free survival
at two years of 64%, so that looks better with a nice tail. All the events occurred in the early
phase, the patients were either primarily refractory to chemotherapy, and two deaths
occurred during the stem cell transplant. And it's similar to other aggressive lymphomas,
where the PFS curve is the same as the overall survival curves, because
outcomes are just worse if you don't respond to initial therapy.
Just in summary, different subtypes have different amounts of CD30 expression. We talked about ALCL,
AITL, and PTCL. Their expression ranges between, it's around 60% to 70%. AITL might have actually
a single-agent at least higher response rate and more durable responses. Another disease where we
use it very often, based on also randomized data, is MF.
It's a very common type of disease that we see in patients with ALCL and CSERVY syndrome,
due to the ALCANZA trial, where we see good activity, irrespective of CD30 expression.
And just wanted to end with this slide. This has been recently presented, and trying to answer the
question from Echelon 2, where only patients with 10% or more were enrolled. However, the FDA approval
is for any CD30 expression. So here, investigators enrolled patients with less than 10% CD30 and broke it down into 2%.
So here, investigators enrolled patients with less than 10% CD30 and broke it down into 2%.
So here, investigators enrolled patients with less than 10% CD30 and broke it down into 2%. So you see, in the CD30, there are two groups, CD30 less than 1, or 1 to less than 10%. And you see numerically, so you see it's still a very good CR rate of, and overall response rate of 61 to 81%, slightly higher numerically. Again, it was empowered to be compared, but numerically higher in the CD30 detectable, low detectable range. And that corresponded to also numerically looking better progression-free survival and all of that.
Overall survival for those who have at least 1 plus percent expression, but certainly very interesting and not looking worse than what the job for sure. So not sure how we take this further, but generally confirming that if you have any CD30 expression, it's considered BV chip. In conclusion, BV has made a huge impact in T cell lymphoma, and particularly in ALCL, but BV chip
clearly is the standard of care. The role of BV chip in non-ALCL is less clear, but hopefully we answered the question. It's certainly, in my opinion, not worse than CHOP. BV has moderate to modest activity in some other subtypes, particularly in CTCL, and there are some subtypes like EATL and maybe AITL, where there's been a study with BV-CHOEP as induction that had seen high response rate that may benefit, and BV combinations in
the relapse setting are being explored. And with that, I'd like to thank you for your attention.